welcome to part whatever is head on the
[ __ ] elevator I'm [ __ ] pissed at
this game
surgery was spent helping mark there was
no way for him to know that the young
man
the other day cause such terrible share
of shadow
all right heading down there to later
that can only be good into things
I was not too Pleasant
all right
well good thing we use the [ __ ]
elevator the morning sun flickered
between the pine trees and the carriage
approached the castle a faint memory of
reflection in the window over I have no
idea look up no don't quit on me now
Danielle we're not nearly done with this
[ __ ] League
I believe until I'm done either
alright let's see come this way
I wonder what's up leaders forgive me I
should have warned you one of my
responsibilities as a baron is that of a
prison warden this is where criminals
are load up like a double jump very much
so
come don't linger linger
what does linger mean all these fancy
words
all right
it's gotta be some way yeah there we go
I'm a strong [ __ ]
I kill you Alexander I see your face I'm
gonna shop it off as you did with that
dog that is not cool killing dogs
dog wanted to kiss me
that's gonna sound weird PC look didn't
wash their losses all right we're good
remove this
and remove the lock then we can know the
lock at the door
Oh Oh No
oh I seen this part in the live stream
just just like a minute or so so I don't
know what and when
or whatever but I know the monster will
appear
bah
yeah yeah yeah
you're not my bro anymore I love the
rope
scaring your bro consistently it's not
this make you I gotta let this up cuz I
get a feeling I'm gonna come back here
I have 15 of those man [ __ ] so dark I
can't lift those yeah [ __ ] I hate you I
hate I [ __ ] hate you you're not my
bro you're not my bro you're not my bro
bro no no no no no all right
I knew it I'm so sick of him
Oh
how do I know if you will here
I don't want to die
I don't want to go in the Saint
there bro
can't really hurt
okay let's have here that
Jesus Christ that's a shot
Oh
yeah yeah you're scared of the [ __ ] is
it
this [ __ ] bet
[ __ ] [ __ ] ahead
all right got our hammer maybe we can
stone into death that would be [ __ ]
Pleasant I don't know why how you stone
someone with
let's use our hammer to bang this
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh I still had that one
though very got
nope nope nope
not going in there
Tallis up with this it's like a delay
it's annoying
stop it oh that's why I'm insane
I'm not a twitch
nerd
pick it up Daniel [ __ ] so hard with
the delay
who if he had been manually I would
so hard
stop being such a [ __ ] juice isn't
scared Daniel
I'm gonna hammer this [ __ ] lock so
[ __ ] hard solid methyl in good shape
this is no use [ __ ] you I'm gonna do it
anyway
worked no I mean sane oh come on
Danielle you come on don't quit on me
Danielle and you know we're in this
together you [ __ ] douche get up ya
head and pounding hands are shaking your
douche Daniel [ __ ] quitter
oh wait I got this not either
what I might put my dick in it or what
seriously
that doesn't work I'm out of my [ __ ]
ideas I guess I gotta find something
ah geez surprise
your quitter Daniel you know work for
the team
just [ __ ] do
it's down there
something professional maybe I can use
something
I'm stupid for even trying this I just
hey there
alright cutscene
mother I don't want to leave without you
hurry time you must go flying Gabriel
the outlet oh sorry Kingsman
please we don't have time to make the
hole any wider like a hole in her vagina
it's coming hurry
I'll cover the hole with the bed oh it's
under the man as I promised close the
door so I don't like alright
good
enough it's too narrow
so I don't have to take a diet
see if it
but after why do I keep this stuff you
know if I can release them pretty
useless yeah yeah what is mice yeah [ __ ]
he's after me close the door
please don't come in here what have I
done bro you're not my bro [ __ ] you
am i doing i'm just gonna call captain
in the corner
and the corner
in the corner
all the ways always works
can't see [ __ ]
even the mice are scared got them
[ __ ] I don't feel like I have the
right to call anyone a [ __ ] I've been
so scared playing this game is it gone
or what hate them hate you all right
yeah yeah
yeah said asked to she had fall over
that
right so there were like nothing in here
I feel like I'm gonna run out of oil if
I keep using it like this
I really don't want it
I'm